This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6MuteEnglish
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English,
the show that brings you an interesting topic,
authentic listening practice and six items
of incredibly useful vocabulary.
I'm Dan and I'm Neil.
Now, a favourite topic today.
Food and how food could influence your mood.
Dan, tell me, what food makes you happy?
Oh, you know, ice cream, chocolate.
Chocolate always puts a smile on my face.
And a few inches around your waistline.
Sadly, the research we'll be looking at today
doesn't suggest you eat more chocolate,
but it does talk about bacteria.
Bacteria.
Those simple, small organisms.
They make me happy.
Absolutely.
The so-called good bacteria do.
We'll get to that, but first we'll look at today's question.
How many bacteria are there in the human body?
Is it A39 million, B39 billion, or C39 trillion?
Hmm.
They are pretty small.
I'm going to go for C39 trillion.
Well, we'll find out if you're right
by counting them one by one.
That's going to take longer than six minutes.
Yes, it is. So let's get moving.
Scientists believe your mental state
is connected to the bacteria in your gut.
My gut, my stomach, and the other organs
my food passes through.
Yes, researchers at McMaster University
and Canada and University College
cork in Ireland have found that certain bacteria
help produce anxiety in mice.
Anxiety.
The state of being worried or anxious.
I don't like the sound of an anxious mouse.
Well, I'm afraid there's another mouse experiment coming up.
Researchers at Kyushu University found
germ-free mice showed more stress.
Germs. A general word for bacteria and microorganisms.
Usually the ones which cause disease.
So germs help reduce stress and anxiety in mice.
Hmm. Any research on humans?
The BBC TV program Trust Me.
I'm a doctor has just explored this.
They looked at foods which are high in good bacteria.
The claim which more and more food products
are making these days.
Yes, it's a phrase that appears a lot in marketing.
But many traditional foods are high in good bacteria as well.
They found that homemade fermented food was best.
So things like miso soup, kimchi, yogurt, sourcrow,
all these are fermented.
Have you tried all of those?
Mmm, I love miso soup and kimchi.
And fermentation is the process where sugars in food are turned into acids and alcohol.
Femented foods are full of lots of good bacteria for your gut.
Anything else from the BBC program?
Well, this is the man behind the BBC study.
Dr. Michael Mosley in this clip, a radio presenter,
asks him about the best kind of food to make us happy.
What's the good mood food?
What shall we eat now to cheer ourselves up?
Mediterranean diet, olive oil,
oily fish full of omega-3, which is really good for the brain,
whole grains, fruit vegetables, sugar, terrible food.
Not chocolate or clairs.
Sadly not, that would make you feel good.
Dark sugar, good for about 30 seconds.
It's actually finishing.
Then you feel terribly, terribly guilty.
Right. Okay, Mediterranean.
He said the best kind of food is the Mediterranean diet.
Now, a diet can mean an eating plan designed to help you lose weight.
But that's not what it means here.
Here it refers to the food and drink eaten by a group of people.
In this case, the people living around the Mediterranean see.
Lots of oily fish, olive oil, grains, fruits and vegetables.
And of course, add in plenty of fermented food too.
And don't eat too many fatty sugary chocolatey things,
like chocolate or clairs.
Those buns filled with cream and covered in chocolate,
it's really not rocket science, is it?
Eating healthy is pretty straightforward,
even if the science behind it is complex.
When you say something is not rocket science,
you mean it's not difficult to understand.
Now, are you ready for some counting?
Ah, yes.
You wanted me to count all the bacteria in my body.
I said 39 trillion.
And you were right.
Woo-hoo!
The number goes up and down,
but on average, we're thought to have
around 39 trillion bacterial cells in the body,
according to the Weisman Institute in Israel.
The interesting thing is they think
that there are only 30 trillion human cells in the body.
So there's more bacteria than human in me?
Well, maybe just you, Dan.
Now, before the bacteria take over completely,
let's look over today's words one more time.
Gut was first.
It means the stomach and other organs which digest our food.
But here's an extra tip.
The word can also mean bravery when used in the plural.
You've got guts, Neil, wearing that crazy shirt in this office.
Well, thank you.
Maybe I don't feel any anxiety about how I look.
Anxiety was our second word,
and it means fear or worry.
The adjective is anxious.
You know what makes me anxious?
Germs.
I washed my hands 50 times a day.
I can't stand the idea of getting ill
from all the germs around here.
Yes, germs are tiny organisms.
The word usually refers to those which carry disease.
But as we heard, certain germs are good for you.
Especially those which are in fermented food.
That's food which has gone through a process
where sugars turn into acids and alcohol.
They often taste sour or bitter.
We also talk about fermenting alcoholic drinks.
Beer and wine are fermented.
Does that mean I should make them a part of my diet?
A diet not only means a healthy eating plan,
but can also mean the foods and drinks consumed
by an individual or group.
Which country has the best diet, Neil?
Well, in my opinion, the Japanese diet.
It's my favorite anyway.
Very varied and plenty of fermented food.
And finally, we had it's not rocket science.
It's simple to understand.
An example?
Brewing beer isn't rocket science.
You just need hops, yeast, and patience.
And there we are, a rocket speed review of today's words.
And that's the end of today's 6 Minute English.
Please join us again soon.
And we are on social media too.
Make sure to visit us on Facebook, Twitter, Instagram, and YouTube.
Goodbye.
6 Minute English.
From BBC Learning English.